hi everybody i'm scarlett johansson and
i play ash in sing two this person over
here i'm bruce witherspoon
and i play rosita in sing two and we're
taking the buzzfeed which sing to
character matches your personality quiz
let's do it let's do it
first where do you get your best singing
done in the shower car karaoke bedroom
concert singing is it for me i'm gonna
say the car see i sound really good in
the car um i think the shower which sing
two character would you take a road trip
with meena new she miss crawley darius
jimmy crystal or gunta
wunder maybe mina she's cute i'm gonna
say gunter because he's funny how would
your friends describe your singing
comical agonizing surprising soothing
powerful immediately no
oh boy comical really maybe no i would
think your friends think you're amazing
you have the most gorgeous voice that's
very so good in the movie you're that's
very very kind and i do not believe that
your voice is comical that's ridiculous
maybe soothing hmm
choose a song to get the party started
dual leap is levitating megan the
stallion's thought
josiah cats kissed me more justin
bieber's peaches the weeknd's blinding
lights or drake's way too sexy i'm gonna
say uh the weeknd's blinding lights um
good one i like levitating that dua lipa
song lana sings it in the trailer every
day pick a skill you wish you were
better at public speaking cooking
dancing
language learning driving socializing
language learning for me oh okay i'm
gonna go
i'm a terrible driver
i'm a terrible driver
yeah i get in fender benders you do
you're just little oh my god thanks for
the warning
don't drive anywhere with me what movie
are you watching for movie night let's
see okay reese rent hamilton chicago
mamma mia or the wiz
hmm
i really like chicago
i thought it was fun probably
the whiz
whoa oh my gosh
you wet yourself
i got buster moon what yeah i don't
believe that well what does it say about
apparently he's also a terrible driver
yeah that's right
it's so hard he doesn't see him in the
dash you're ambitious creative and
optimistic that's true like buster
you're someone who loves to live life to
the fullest your confidence is admirable
because even during your darkest days
you manage to find the light thanks
bester oh that's probably true yeah
that's sweet
i just i believe that you seem like a
very optimistic person
thanks for saying that no problem okay
read george i'm ash you're resilient
compassionate and brave like ash there's
someone who knows what they want and
you're willing to do whatever it takes
er to achieve your dreams you also have
a heart of gold so good vibes tend to
follow you wherever you go
i love it goodbye that's a good one
there's a bag
you're the crystal whatever the guy is
oh yeah you're like self-serving and
creepy
[Music]
you